on september 29 1982 in a chicago suburb
12 year old mary kellerman woke and
complained to her parents she was coming
down with a cold they gave her two extra
strength tylenol acetaminophen capsules
shortly after that they found mary on
the bathroom floor and rushed her to the
hospital she was dead just a little
while later
doctors suspected she might have had a
stroke but that's rare in someone so
young
the same day in another chicago suburb
paramedics were called to the home of
adam janus a 27-year-old postal worker
by the time they arrived adam was
unconscious they rushed him to the
hospital but he died soon after of a
suspected heart attack
that evening adam's family gathered at
his home to make plans for his untimely
funeral
adam's 19-year-old sister-in-law theresa
had a headache
her husband 25-year-old stanley janus
saw a bottle of extra strength tylenol
on his brother's counter
stanley and his wife each took a couple
of the capsules a little while later
both collapsed and paramedics were again
called to adam janice's home
authorities evacuated the rest of the
family immediately thinking there might
be some kind of toxic gas leak or
something
stanley died that night and his wife
theresa two days later
obviously the deaths of three young
people from the same family at the same
location were very suspicious
forensic investigators suspected
poisoning and blood samples were taken
from all three of them for toxicology
when someone dies unexpectedly forensic
death investigators routinely examine
the scene and question witnesses family
members or co-workers
this helps pathologists establish cause
and manner of death
these investigators try to find links
between circumstances events and
materials surrounding the loss of life
when these chicago-area death
investigations led to the discovery that
mary kellerman and all three of the
janus family members had taken extra
strength tylenol before their deaths
police rush back to the scenes and
confiscated the bottles of acetaminophen
forensic chemistry indicated several of
the remaining capsules were tainted with
very high levels of potassium cyanide
thousands of times the lethal amount
johnson and johnson the makers of
tylenol were quickly alerted and very
rapidly issued an extensive product
recall of 31 million bottles
but by that time three more women in the
chicago area had also already taken the
drug and were dead
27 year old mary reiner who had just
given birth days before
35 year old flight attendant paula
prince
and 31 year old mary mcfarland who
collapsed in her office at the phone
company comparing the locations of the
victims homes investigators thought it
highly unlikely that they'd all
purchased the medication from the same
store
investigators used the lot numbers on
the bottles to see if they'd all come
from the same manufacturing plant they
didn't so johnson and johnson probably
wasn't the source either through
accident or sabotage
some of you might clearly remember the
media attention in this terrible case i
know i do
the tylenol poisoning was all over the
national news and panic was spreading
but it was so important to get the word
out
chicago police cars traveled up and down
the streets using loudspeakers to warn
the public not to take tylenol
johnson offered a hundred thousand
dollars in reward money for information
leading to the capture of those involved
investigators removed the product from
short store shelves across the whole
nation for forensic testing
only eight adulterated packages were
ultimately recovered in this hideous
death lottery but who knows how many
poison packages consumers could have
thrown away after hearing about the
recall
the eight tainted packages included the
five involved in the deaths two others
returned to stores and one found on a
store shelf
a combination of store receipts and
surveillance videos helped investigators
figure out the eight bottles of tainted
medication came from seven different
locations
in those days store surveillance
equipment wasn't nearly as common as it
is today
no usable fingerprints were recovered
from any of the packaging or contents
and each of the eight bottles had from
three to ten contaminated capsules in it
the best investigators could figure was
that someone was taking extra strength
tylenol bottles from stores
either stealing or buying them then
opening the gel caps adding cyanide and
returning the products to store shelves
to be purchased by unsuspecting victims
now you can imagine how quickly forensic
scientists and the illinois department
of health had to mobilize for this
massive test of product tampering
they developed a rapid test that was a
small slip of chemically treated paper
that could be put into a bottle
the strip would turn blue if cyanide was
present
we call these types of quick assays
field tests or sometimes screening tests
they allow rapid presumptive
identification
if a substance tests positive it's then
subjected to what we call confirmatory
tests which involve more sophisticated
chemical analysis and high-tech lab
equipment
something investigators looked into was
who could have gotten their hands on
potassium cyanide
it is used in some industrial settings
and in the mining industry so
investigators look for any leads in
those directions
they also considered people who might
have been disgruntled with johnson and
johnson and maybe wanted to punish the
company by ruining its reputation
the fbi and several chicago police
agencies came up with suspects and about
400 people were interviewed
the first major suspect was a
do-it-yourself chemist named roger
arnold
he worked at the loading dock at one of
the stores involved and had a weak
connection to another store where
tainted capsules were found
tylenol victim mary reiner's father was
one of arnold's co-workers so initially
police wondered if arnold had some kind
of grudge against mary's father and
maybe use the other killings to try to
disguise his one real target
investigators couldn't pin the crimes on
arnold but he did end up having a mental
breakdown from all the media attention
he thought a guy he knew from a local
tavern had steered police to him and
arnold decided to shoot the man
but one night outside the bar arnold
actually shot a different guy that he
mistook for his intended target so that
innocent man was really another casualty
of the tylenol killings
arnold was convicted of second-degree
murder was paroled after 15 years of a
30-year sentence and died in 2008.
anyway while arnold was being cleared of
suspicion in 1982 the tylenol
investigation quickly turned to a more
promising suspect
johnson and johnson received an
anonymous letter with a new york
postmark
the handwritten letter while not
technically admitting to be from the
killer described how perfect the
poisoning had gone and how simple it was
to put the cyanide in the gel caps
the person claimed it required less than
10 minutes per bottle to complete the
task and hadn't even cost fifty dollars
the letter said the whole plan was a
quote beauty
this was because the bitter poison was
housed in the capsules so couldn't be
tasted
plus cyanide required such a small
amount to be fatal and acted so quickly
that realistically nothing could be done
to save the victims
the letter told johnson and johnson
executives to deposit a million dollars
to a specific account at the continental
illinois bank in chicago if they wanted
the deaths and the bad press to stop
was this letter really from the tylenol
killer or was it a prank
or could it have been from an unrelated
extortionist who wanted to capitalize on
the poisonings
the bank account listed in the letter
was closed but had previously belonged
to frederick miller mccahey he was one
of the heirs to the miller brewing
company and had run a chicago travel
agency that recently went bankrupt
but why on earth would a man put his own
bank account number in an extortion
letter like that could someone be trying
to frame him
what investigators didn't yet know was
that one of mckay he's former employees
his bookkeeper leanne lewis and her
husband james lewis well they were
furious with him
they had even tried to sue mccahe in the
summer of 1982 just months before the
tylenol poisonings because they'd been
stiffed on a bad paycheck the travel
agency bounced
now to get the full picture here we need
to go back into the couple's lives a bit
although he was in his mid-30s in 1982
james lewis's history included a really
difficult upbringing and a diagnosis of
schizophrenia
he had earned good grades in school and
had been pretty involved there but was
known to have some serious problems at
home
in his late teenage years lewis
allegedly chased around his adoptive
mother with an axe and beat up her
husband before trying to kill himself
with an overdose of anisin an
over-the-counter pain reliever
he recovered at a mental health facility
and later claimed the attacks and
suicide attempt were just a ploy to get
him out of the draft since this was
during the vietnam war
later while attending the university of
missouri in kansas city he met and
married leanne and soon after they had a
baby with down syndrome
so the couple opened their own
accounting and tax service in kansas
city that way they could have their
daughter with them at work each day
supposedly the little girl would sit in
the store window and wave at people on
the street
now one day an older man named raymond
west saw the child stopped into the
store and befriended the family
west was a retired bachelor who lived in
the kansas city neighborhood where the
lewis has had their business
he quickly became a tax client and grew
even closer to the couple after their
little girl died following heart surgery
when she was just five years old
some three and a half years later in the
summer of 1978
raymond west made his usual sunday stop
at the local florist
and among other things that were
discussed he complained of not feeling
well
that's the last time anyone saw him
alive now the death of raymond west is a
puzzle in itself within this whole
tylenol story but i'll summarize it by
saying that his decomposed and
dismembered body was found in his home
three weeks later in the kansas city
summer
now let's see how james lewis connects
to that
while west was missing a concerned
friend had tried several times to
contact him
he went to west's house and after seeing
the man's unmade bed through an open
window shade he called police who agreed
to look into it
the same friend then returned a little
later to west's house
only to find the same window shade
closed and a note on the door
the note on lewis and lewis tax firm
letterhead stated that raymond west was
out of town for a few days and anybody
who had questions could call james lewis
now this made west's friend really
suspicious so he got police to do a
cursory search of the house they
actually had to break the door lock to
enter but they found nothing really
unusual except west wasn't there
later when this concerned friend was
putting in a new lock at west's house
james lewis showed up to ask what was
going on and the two men talk for a
while
but when three weeks passed with no word
from raymond west his friend used the
key to the new lock he just installed
when he opened the door the smell of
decomposition almost knocked him over
police came back and found things
weren't exactly the way they'd been
during the first search
besides the smell there was a bloody
lawn chair in the basement and a garbage
bag that held bloodstained sheets and
west's hairpiece and glasses
but the basement didn't seem to be where
the odor was coming from so they went
back upstairs and saw a bloody stain
oozing through the drywall on the
bedroom ceiling
the dismembered body parts of a man
assumed to be raymond west had been
hoisted up into the attic using some
kind of a pulley system
as for positive id
this was prior to forensic dna testing
the remains were too decomposed for
fingerprints and west were dentures made
by a lab that was no longer in operation
the body was determined to be his
through a hair match between a little
hair west had left and a hair found in
one of his hats plus of course wes was
still missing
now how is james lewis further linked to
this gruesome discovery
by a check from raymond west's bank
account made out to lewis for five
thousand dollars and dated on the last
day the old man was seen alive
when police brought lewis in he said the
money was alone that the bank didn't
even honor anyway since they couldn't
reach west for verification
officers point blank as lewis if he had
any of raymond west's checks and he said
no
lewis willingly submitted to a
handwriting sample and fingerprints and
police let him go while they continued
to investigate
the next day officers went to lewis's
house and requested to search his home
his tax agency and his vehicle
in lewis's car investigators found
garbage bags and rope like those at the
crime scene they also found some of
west's personal papers and a pack of his
blank checks lewis still denied any
involvement in the man's death but they
charged him
lewis's trial for the 1978 murder of
raymond west was set to begin in the
fall of 1979
but the charges ended up dismissed due
to some legal missteps along the way
for one thing lewis hadn't been read his
miranda rights which rendered everything
that was collected as evidence
inadmissible in court
there were also errors in the legal
filings
besides west's body was so decomposed
that the county coroner couldn't provide
either a cause or manner of death
so even if the prosecution could show
that lewis dismembered west's body and
even tried to steal or extort money from
the old man there was likely no way they
could prove lewis killed him
although james lewis was free police
were determined to try to find some way
to put him behind bars
they continued to investigate his tax
business as well as other ventures lewis
partnered in
one of which coincidentally or not
involved the import of machinery used to
manufacture pills
by the end of 1981 authorities had
amassed enough evidence to get a search
warrant for lewis home
they collected files as well as
typewriter ribbons that i assume they
were going to use for ink comparisons on
some question documents
but this time rather than waiting around
to see what happened james lewis and his
wife went on the run
they left kansas city for chicago
where the couple assumed the names
robert and nancy richardson
that's where nancy who was really leanne
lewis went to work for frederick miller
mccahey's doomed travel agency
now that was quite a side track in the
investigations of the 1982 tylenol
killings but i think it's an important
one
it sets us up to know much more about
james lewis
who you can probably already guess
becomes the second major suspect in the
poisonings
it also explains how he and his wife
came to chicago using false names
following which leanne's employment
unraveled to the point where the couple
wanted to get even with mccahe
all for a bounced paycheck in the amount
of 511 dollars in change
regarding the lewis's attempt to punish
mccahey
james lewis was instrumental in trying
to mobilize the travel agency's former
employees to take action with the
illinois department of labor
lewis also had leanne contact one of her
former supervisors to get a list of
mckayy's bank account numbers i assume
maybe to find out if they had any money
left to go after
if you remember the tylenol extortion
letter provided one of mckay he's bank
account numbers
james lewis also helped the former
employees get a hearing with the
illinois department of labor
james was said to be the most outspoken
of the group even though he had never
even worked for the travel agency nor
was any type of official representative
for them
in fact the person at the hearing
finally told lewis he needed to just sit
in the corner and listen
when the meeting was almost over mckay
he showed up
at that point witnesses said that he and
the lewis couple began yelling at each
other ending with mckay he threatening
leanne lewis
now when their claim against mckay he
went nowhere james and leanne or robert
and nancy richardson as they were called
the whole time they were in chicago well
they decided to leave town
using the names william and karen wagner
now the couple bought one-way train
tickets for new york city and left on
september 4th 1982.
that was 25 days before 12 year old mary
kellerman died from the cyanide lace
tylenol
surprisingly when the pair hit new york
they took back their chicago names as
robert and nancy richardson
authorities hadn't connected james and
leanne lewis to any of this yet i was
just giving you the back story
as for the investigation of the tylenol
murders all police knew early on was
that mccahe's account number was in that
extortion letter
and that it was postmarked from new york
just days after the poisonings
during the forensic analysis of the
envelope
when investigators scratched the
postmark away they found an office
postage meter stamp from mccahe's travel
agency dated april of 1982.
although police didn't know it yet that
was because leanne lewis had metered
some blank envelopes when she still
worked for mccahe she took them home and
then months later used one of them to
send the extortion letter from new york
so there were several lines leading to
mccahe but he was kind of a prominent
guy in the area
police just didn't think he'd be foolish
enough to implicate himself like that
in either the extortion or the tylenol
killings
among the first things they asked mckay
he was who might have been upset with
him for some reason he immediately said
robert and nancy richardson
it didn't take long for police to figure
out the couple's legal names were james
and leanne lewis
but they had left chicago for new york
by this time and no one really knew
where they'd gone
investigators initially thought the
extortion letter was just a hoax to
bring mccahe into the limelight and
embarrass him but after police learned
of james lewis's connection to the
raymond west dismemberment case back in
kansas city as well as the business and
tax fraud that caused him to leave
missouri well then they reconsidered
by this time the couple's faces and
aliases were all over the media and they
needed to really drop out of sight
quickly
leanne quit the job she'd just gotten in
new york they moved out of their
apartment and stopped using the names
robert and nancy richardson
people who knew the couple at one time
or another started coming forward to the
press and police at this time
some said james lewis was a near genius
that could talk on almost any subject
but others said he was mentally unstable
cold and vindictive
things got really crazy when it was
reported that lewis had also written a
threatening letter to president ronald
reagan alleging it was from mccahe
handwriting analysis showed the same
person had written both letters and they
found lewis's fingerprint on the
extortion letter
then lewis began writing to the press
just like some other killers have done
including ted kaczynski the unabomber
and dennis rader the btk killer
lewis sent a package of material to a
chicago newspaper
the paper is related to the travel
agency payroll default
i suppose to try and indicate that
framing mckay he was with good reason
but lewis's letter stated that he and
his wife did not commit the tylenol
murders how could they after moving to
new york weeks before the deaths
co-workers saw leanne daly at her new
york job and also saw james meter for
lunch and at the bus station daily
authorities never did find any public
transportation records to indicate
either of them had returned to chicago
during the tylenol killings
in another letter lewis mocked police
for reopening the raymond west case and
again trying to connect him to it
lewis began signing his real name
he even put his right thumb print on one
letter after the media reported the fbi
had recently discovered lewis's right
thumb print on the pulley system that
had been used in the raymond west case
since leanne who generally supported
them had quit her job they needed money
about two months after the tylenol
killings a manhattan western union
surveillance camera captured leanne
picking up a 140 money order that had
been sent to her by her father so
authorities knew the couple was still in
the area
but the big break came next when the fbi
received a call from a new york public
librarian
who said she thought she had just given
the wanted man james lewis two
references he had requested
one was a listing of newspaper outlets
and their addresses and he was still
presently sitting at a table in the
library
agents immediately closed in and
arrested lewis but really all they had
enough evidence to charge him with was
the extortion
leanne turned herself in and although
investigators bargained with her to turn
against her husband she refused
the only thing they could charge her on
was social security fraud for using
identification that wasn't hers during
her prior employment
about a year after the tylenol killings
james lewis was convicted of attempted
extortion he got 10 years in prison to
be served consecutively with 10 years he
got for other charges like tax fraud
while in prison lewis wanted to work
with the authorities to try to solve the
poisonings now they agreed in the hopes
that maybe he would slip up he didn't
but neither would he take a lie detector
test
lewis was a model prisoner for 13 years
until his release in 1995.
good old leanne was still waiting for
him
since then jim lewis has been living in
the boston area
he maintains he was a political prisoner
who served as a scapegoat for an inept
investigation
lewis says that while he sat in jail and
since he remains a prime suspect the
real tylenol murderer has gone free
in 2004 lewis was arrested for the rape
and kidnapping of a woman in cambridge
massachusetts
despite being held for three years
awaiting trial the case was dropped on
the eve of the court proceedings because
the victim decided she wouldn't testify
in 2009 the fbi searched lewis's home as
part of what they called a quote ongoing
investigation
citing the possibility of new evidence
and technological advances that might
finally help them solve the crime
my guess is they were referring to
what's called touch dna testing
developed just about that same time in
which only a handful of human skin cells
maybe as few as six or eight can create
a dna profile
agents were seen leaving lewis's home
with boxes of papers and an apple
computer they also searched a storage
facility in the cambridge area but no
charges were filed as a result
in 2010 the fbi asked james lewis and
his wife to submit dna samples as well
as fresh fingerprints and they complied
unbelievably also in 2010 lewis released
a self-published novel that he had the
audacity to title poison
he gave a 45-minute interview to a
boston public access show to try to
promote his book
you can find video clips of the
interview on the internet the whole
thing is very bizarre
lewis said the book is totally fictional
and is set in the kind of rural area he
grew up in
the storyline is about a well that's
intentionally contaminated with mercury
causing people in the area to die
he said there's no message about the
tylenol case intended by his work and he
still maintains he had nothing to do
with it
he's also said that if he had any idea
of what the extortion letter did to the
victims
by redirecting the investigation onto
him instead of the real killer well he'd
never have written the letter
another strange twist in 2011 the
convicted and imprisoned so-called
unabomber ted kaczynski was also asked
by the fbi to submit a dna sample for
evaluation in the 1982 tylenol killings
now he grew up in the chicago area and
at the time of the tylenol case
kaczynski's parents still had a home
there that he occasionally visited
four of his attacks occurred in chicago
between 1978 and 1980.
kaczynski tried to bargain with the fbi
filing a motion saying he would give the
sample only if they would stop the
pending auction of his belongings
including items seized from the montana
cabin where he had lived
the auction was an attempt to raise
money for his victims
the unabomber said the 30 thousand pages
of his journals in particular would show
he couldn't have committed the tylenol
poisoning but the auction went on
2012 marked the 30th anniversary of the
tylenol murders
that year media reports indicated that a
grand jury might finally be convened to
indict james lewis in the seven murders
that never happened
even lead investigators on the case
disagree on whether or not lewis is
actually responsible for the killings
today some describe the case as one of
the earliest examples of what many would
now call domestic or homegrown terrorism
either james lewis or somebody else
randomly targeted the general public to
cause fear
and i'm quoting here from one of the men
involved in the investigation from its
beginning
bring the country to its knees
since then american america and other
places in the world have seen all too
many examples of this kind of random
violence
cases in which targets aren't hand
selected by mad men who single out
victims for their own demented reasons
instead we've seen the indiscriminate
killings of groups of fellow americans
such as in the sandy hook and other
school shootings the boston marathon
bombings the shootings at fort hood
texas or the oklahoma city bombing
some experts disagree with calling the
tylenol killings terrorism
because by their definition terrorism
involves a clear motive or goal
that's politically or religiously
motivated and often involves a person or
group that claims responsibility
at this point the 1982 tylenol deaths
themselves are no mystery
in a span of just three days seven
people were killed using cyanide-laced
acetaminophen acetaminophen capsules
what remains unknown is who did this
terrible thing and why
in the fall of 2013 the fbi announced it
could no longer serve as lead
investigator in the killings
the case has just grown too cold
despite ever advancing forensic
technology there are just no fresh clues
and all existing leads have been
exhausted
i guess that means they still found no
definitive connection to james lewis ted
kaczynski or anyone else at this point
still chicago area police have not given
up several agencies have started their
own task force to continue to pursue the
tylenol killer
[Music]
you